Dr Joel Walla grew up in a farm in the
1950s and he noticed that the animals on
the farm were getting better nutrition
than the people were and he asked his
dad about it and Dad just basically told
him to shut up but he noticed that all
of the ailments that were afflicting the
animals on the farm could be treated
with proper nutrition and he wondered
why this could not be done in humans and
when he did get around the treating it
in humans he realized that it worked for
humans as well and we're talking about
major illnesses like cancer and stroke
and heart problems and osteoporosis and
arthritis and name it hundreds of them
can be treated with proper nutrition and
we're in instead we're going down to the
doctors and spending trillions of
dollars a year on stuff that we just
don't
need Dr wallik um is not exactly a Fly
by Night outfit either in 1991 he was
nominated for the Nobel Prize for
medicine and in in the late 1990s he
started this country company called
youngevity where there are many
representatives all around the country
country who are taking testimonials
every day at the benefits of the
products that Dr wallik has helped
develop and in 1994 he made this tape
his most famous tape excuse me that's
called Dead Doctors Don't Lie and it's
being distributed nowadays by youngevity
Representatives but not in the tape form
that you that you're about to hear it
was cut down to size so that it could
fit all on one CD well the original tape
doesn't fit on one CD and that's why you
don't see people promoting that one CD
because it doesn't fit in 80 80 minutes
well the cassette tape is the most
important thing to have because you'll
get the entire lecture of what he said
back in this audience in 1994 in Kansas
City everything that he said is going to
be on this tape that you're about to
hear and when I play the tape at the
first part of it I'm going to scroll
down his biography so you can get an
idea of the extent of CR credentials
that Dr wallik has I can tell you I've
been supplementing with this product
since 1996 and I'm very very glad that I
have because when my friends talk about
how their health problems are all I can
do is sit there and stare at them
because I don't have any at all so now
sit back and relax and listen as you
hear Dr Wallock and Dead Doctors Don't
Lie in the original
tape Dr wallik is going to explain to
you tonight not only about cardiac
myopathy but many other things I pray
that you listen closely and carefully
because what you're do to hear May save
your life or the life of your loved one
Dr wck in 1991 was nominated for the
Nobel Prize he had many many fabulous
things in his
life there's no way I can tell you how
pleased I am to have him here in Kansas
City tonight and I want to turn the time
over now to Dr Joel wallik would you all
give him a big hand
how many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock I'll tell you what you're
my kind of people because I grew up on a
farm in West St Louis County back in the
50s and we start out with beef Cales and
uh if if you raise livestock the only
way you can make money is if you raise a
lot of your own feed for those of you
don't have that experience and so we
raised our own corn and we raised our
own soybeans in our own hay and we had a
truck come out from the mill and this
truck would come out from the mill and
it would grind up the corn and the
soybeans and the hay and then we would
add sacks of vitamins minerals trace
minerals and we'd make pellets out of it
and this is what we would feed the Cals
in 6 months time we'd ship them to
Market to be slaughtered we'd save back
some of the best ones for ourself we'd
knock them in the head and eat them put
it bluntly and um it always fascinated
me as a teenager that we did that for
those calvs and then six months ship
them off to be slaughtered or weed eat
them and we wanted to live to be 100
years of age without any aches and pains
and guess what we didn't take any
vitamins or minerals and that bothered
me so I asked my dad I'd say hey Pops
how come you do that for those Cavs you
don't do that for us and he'd give me
this good old Missouri farm wisdom he'd
say things like shut up boy you're
getting this farm fresh food and we hope
you appreciate it and of course I was
very quiet then because I didn't want to
miss out on any meals well then when I
went to school I went to the University
of Missouri the
School of Agriculture and I got my
degree in agriculture and it was very
interesting to me that I got my major in
animal husbandry and nutrition my minor
was in field crops and soils then I got
into veterinary school as a freshman
Veterinary student I learned the answer
to my question and the answer is this we
know how to prevent and cure diseases in
animals with nutrition and the reason
why we do that is because we don't have
major medical we don't have
hospitalization Blue Cross Blue Shield
we don't have um
Medicare we don't have Hillary to watch
out for
us if you're going to make money as a
farmer you better know how to do stuff
yourself and you better uh do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can well to make a long story short
after I got out of veterinary school I
went to Africa for two years and I was
able to fulfill a Boyhood dream I was
able to be a Frank Buck for two years
and work with Marlon Perkins many of you
remember him from the Mutual of Omaha's
Wild Kingdom and he's a great gentleman
and after two years of working with
elephants and rhino people used to ask
me are you a small animal vet or a large
animal vet well I would tell him I'm a
extra large animal vet because I work
with elephants and rhinos well after two
years he sent me a telegram and said
would you come back to the St Louis Zoo
and work with us we need a Wildlife
veterinarian at the zoo for a special
project we were given a 7 and A5 million
Grant from the um National Institutes of
Health and what we need is a
veterinarian who will do autopsies of
animals to die of natural causes in the
zoo well I was just Overjoyed to do that
and so I came back and and did that and
of course I not only did autopsies for
animals that died in the St Louis Zoo
but the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago the
bront zoo in New York the National Zoo
the LA Zoo and so forth and my job again
was to do autopsies of animals that died
of natural causes in the zoo and look
for a species of animals that was Ultra
sensitive to pollution this because
during the early 60s we had just learned
about pollution and EC iCal problems and
disasters and nobody quite knew what to
do and so I was supposed to find a
species of animals that was extra
sensitive to this and use them much like
we did the canaries in the mine you know
the old Welsh coal miners used to put a
canary in a little wicker cage and take
it down in the mine and if methane gas
or carbon monoxide would leak into the
mine the canary would drop off the perch
and die first and the men knew to get
out before the mine blew up or they
suffocated well again to make a long
story short uh over a period of some 12
years I did
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings who lived
in close proximity to zoos and the thing
that I found out was this every animal
and every human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency and that fascinated me it
went back took me back to those calves I
said Gee that's fascinating everybody's
dying of nutritional deficiencies and we
could document this at autopsy both
chemically and biochemically and so
forth and things you saw with the eye at
the autopsy table well that fascinated
me and I wrote 75 scientific articles I
wrote uh eight multi-author textbooks
and one textbook of my own cost 140
bucks for medical students and I'm sure
the only thing they do is use them for
door
stops and I couldn't get anybody excited
I was on
2020 uh I was on 1700
newspapers I was in magazines I was in
every new network TV that you can think
of and guess what couldn't get anybody
excited back in the 60s about
nutrition so what I did was went back to
school and became a physician to use
everything I had learned in veterinary
school about nutrition and my human
patients and to no surprise to me it
worked I spent 12 years up in Portland
Oregon in general practice and um it was
very fascinating what I'm going to share
with you tonight is what I learned over
those 10 12 years using nutrition with
my human patients and if you take home
only 10% if you take home only 10% it
will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
Gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a go means
a
lot and it will save you and in fact it
will add on many helpful years to your
life okay it'll add many helpful years
to your life well you can't do this you
can't get these helpful years you can't
have longevity you can't live to your
genetic potential just falling off a
stump uh you have to do some things and
the first thing I have to do is convince
you that it is worth doing these things
I'm going to start off by convincing you
that the genetic potential for human
beings is 120 to 140 years our genetic
potential for longevity okay 120 to 140
years there's no less than five cultures
whose people live to be 120 to 140
starts out in the Tibetans in western
China uh these people were popularized
back in
1934 um by James Hilton he wrote a book
called The Lost Horizon many of you will
remember reading that was a puler prize
winning book way back then and they did
a movie of that 1937 it's a very long
movie about 3 hours you can get it from
any Blockbuster Video and I would
encourage you to get it and look at it
when you have three hours it's a great
movie and the oldest living person that
has some documentation I'm sure there's
a certain amount of exaggeration in
there but there is some documentation
was a fellow a Dr Lee lii from China
along this border and this fellow and
when he was 150 years old quote unquote
received a um big certificate from the
Imperial Chinese government uh he was
born in
1677 150 years later he was given a
certificate by the Imperial Chinese
government for being 150 years and then
when he got to be 200 years they sent
him another 50 years later they sent him
another certificate and supposedly he
died at age 256 and as people of that
nature he was written up in the New York
Times in 1933 when he died in the London
times and so this is fairly well
documented but he may have only been 200
years old uh I don't know if he was 256
but this is the
um person that led James Hilton to write
that story then uh there's in
1967 or 68 there was a remake of that
movie it was a color version if you
haven't seen that was called shangra La
I'd urge you to see that then Eastern
Pakistan there's a group of people
called the hunzas and these people are
very famous for longevity 120 140 if
you've been in Alternative Health for
any length of time you heard their name
at least then in what is now Western
Russia used to be the Soviet Union the
Russian Georgians were made famous
during the 70s by Dan and yogurt you
remember the old Crimea War U veterans
they get their uniform on they'd hold a
saber up and they would get a cup of Dan
and yogurt and smile a lot and you're
were supposed to make the mental leap
that it was the Dan and yogurt that made
them live to be
120 then just south of them the
Armenians the aians and the azerbaijanis
are famous at least in in the Soviet
Union they were studied for some 60
years because they routinely lived to be
120 to 140 in fact in 19 uh 73 the
January issue of the 19 of the um uh
National Geographic 1973 January uh
National Geographic did a special
article on people who Liv to be 100 and
our older and they featured these people
and there's a great pictorial article
you know National Geographic is very
good about coming out with pictures and
three of these dozens of pictures that
were in that article I remember one of
them was a lady who was 136 years old
she was sitting in a wicker chair with a
big Cuban cigar in one hand and an 8 o
glass of vodka in the other and she was
partying she was having a good time she
was not in a nursing home all slouched
over and and you know ready to have
somebody take another 2500 bucks out of
her checking account uh she was enjoying
herself at 36 then there was a
semicircle of couples boy girl boy girl
boy girl and they were celebrating their
H 100th and 115th and 120th wedding
anniversaries then the third picture
that I remember is a gentleman who is
picking tea leaves up at the timber line
in the Caucasus Mountains in Armenia and
um he was listening to a one of these
little transistor radios back then and
according to his birth records and and
baptismal records his military records
and the birth records of his children uh
the National Geographic said that he was
167 years of age and the oldest living
person at that time in the Western
Hemisphere the vilcabamba Indians in
Ecuador are very famous they live in the
Andes and then in Southeastern Peru my
favorites the titty kakas I just like
them because I like the name they're
sort of east of the Machu picu the old
Community the titty kakas live around
Lake tit Kaka and of course they're very
famous uh for living to be 120 to 140
well in May 11th just about a month ago
the oldest living American at this time
and documented through the Guinness
World Book of Records was Margaret Ste
she was from Radford Virginia she died
at age of
115 and she died of a nutritional
deficiency you can tell that from her
her
obituary she died of the complications
of a fall what did she die from
osteoporosis very good she died of a
Calcium deficiency she had no heart
disease no cancer no diabetes no other
infirmities but she died 3 weeks after a
fall because she didn't have enough
calcium very interesting also her
daughter said that she had a craving for
sweets until she died and that's a a
disease called Pica we'll talk about
that in a little bit but usually when
you have a craving for chocolate if
you're a chocaholic or a sugarholic that
means that you have a deficiency of
chromium and vadium and we'll talk about
that in a minute then in a third world
country in Niger in Africa a chief by
the name of Bower at age 126 was
eulogized by one his wives so I assume
it was plural it had many wives and she
was bragging about him at his death at
age of 126 he was still in possession of
all his own
teeth okay so you assume that other
faculties are working
too then here's a gentleman uh from
Syria at age 133 he died in July of 1993
and he was in the gness World Book of
Records not because he was 133 there's
been many people live longer than that
um not because he remarried for the
fourth time at age 80 but because he
fathered nine children after the age of
80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child and a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
100 and that's what got him into the
Guinness World Book of Records so
there's still hope for you
fellas then those of you who like
science um in November of
1993 those six biospherians that came
out of that dome in Arizona they were in
there for 2 years
um three couples and they were supposed
to eat the perfect food and recycle the
atmosphere and grow their own food and
what not and have no pollution in their
water or air or food and when they came
out they were examined by medical
gerontologists from UCLA University of
California Los Angeles and uh they put
all this information their physical and
their blood work and so forth into the
medical computers at UCLA and the
medical computer said that and projected
that they could live to be 165 years old
if they continued to do what they were
doing so all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be 120 to 140 and when I
grew up on the farm we could grow 200
bushels of corn per acre and with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did you could make a
profit if you grew 200 bushels per acre
but if you only got a 100 bushels per
acre and put out that same effort and
the same fertilizer cost you'd lose
money and so I want you to think about
it the average lifespan for an American
today is 75.5
the average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is
58 you want to gain 20 years
statistically just don't go to medical
school you want to live to be 120 140
there's only two basic things it's real
simple two things to remember number one
you have to avoid the pitfalls you have
to not step on the landmines I call it
and those you in the military you know
what that means um you do something
stupid like step on one of those things
you kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily and of course if you play
Russian Roulette or smoke excess or
drink excessively or wear a black
sweatsuit and run down the middle of the
highway at 2:00 in the morning you're
going to get struck by a car uh all of
those things are fool hearty but it's
amazing how many tens of thousands of
people die in America from doing those
stupid things every year the last thing
I will share with you on that subject of
avoiding the landmines I suggest very
strongly to you that you avoid going to
doctors and I'm going to back up that
statement which is a pretty strong
statement with a um statement from Ralph
naters group in January of
1993 just about a year and a half ago uh
January 13th he put out a news release
based on a threeyear study on the causes
of death in American hospitals and it
was 1500 page report this three-year
study and I'm not going to waste your
time or Mine by going over the whole
thing word for word but the bottom line
says a lot the bottom line says a lot
and here it is quote this is from Ralph
nater now he's a consumer advocat
advocate for those of you who don't know
him who watches out for us quote 300,000
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote I'm going to read
that figure again because it's a huge
figure quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote now
he didn't say Slipped Away quietly out
of neglect in a corner somewhere while
they're waiting for an x-ray he used the
word killed when you use the word killed
that means there was a procedure the
doctor was doing went wrong somehow that
means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage these people were
killed 300,000 to appreciate how big a
figure that is you have to compare that
with our military losses in Vietnam over
10 years where we lost 56,000 people
over 10 years or an average of only
5,600 a year on a field of battle where
people had guns and artillery and
explosives trying to kill each other and
millions of people poured out into into
the streets and protested that war we
had political Anarchy in the last three
years of the war U students took over
universities and colleges with guns and
explosives National Guardsman shot
students at Ken state in Ohio we chased
a president out of the presidency for
5,600 military personnel a year and
here's one profession that takes your
tax money in the form of Medicare and
Medicaid and kills 300,000 of us year
according to Ralph nater and I believe
him he has no a to grind and you can go
out in the street any day of the week in
any City and there isn't even a crazy
Street Preacher out there with a sign
that says protect us from
doctors I want you to think about that
folks that's number one you have to
avoid stepping on the landmine so
there's a certain value in treating
yourself when you can or preventing
disease they don't have to get treated
now the second thing you have to do
number two is you have to do the
positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to start
out here by just putting a figure up on
the board it's the number 90 and you
need 90 new nutrients in your diet every
day you need 60
minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them in complete numbers and optimal
amounts well I can tell you that I was
one of those nerds back when I was in
college I had a clipboard we didn't have
computers back then so I had a clipboard
and I I was one of those funny guys with
glasses and would walk up and down in
the Student Union there in Columbia and
say do you take vitamins and minerals I
was still fascinated by that and of
course people would kind of look at you
crazy and say well yeah I take vitamin E
and I'd wait for him to come up with the
other 89 and they didn't they just oh I
take vitamin E well today if he asked
people do you take food supplements they
say oh yeah I take
Tums because that's what you know they
hear all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it but
the newspapers know and the magazines
and TV and radio knows that we're
interested in Health and Longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stad the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it sells newspapers well my
favorite article of all time appeared in
Time Magazine April 6th 19 92 and if you
haven't read it I'd urge you to get it
out of the school library or public
library and photocopy it stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator it's a cover article it
says the real power of vitamins new
research shows they may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
Aging again there's six positive pages
in here there's only one negative
sentence and it was issued by a medical
doctor who was asked by the writer of
the article what do you think what do
you think about vitamins and minerals
for people as food supplements and
here's what the doctor said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do you any good
sniffs Dr Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well W up your dollars and throw them
in the toilet and flush them away
because you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right well I'll tell you what after
having done those 17,500 autopsies and
454 species of animals from around the
world and 3,000 humans and liking to be
healthy myself and having children and
grandchildren and not too distant future
great-grandchildren I'd rather pee out
50 cents or dollar a day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals is pretty cheap
insurance because if you don't invest in
yourself to the tune of a bucket day for
vitamins and minerals guess what you're
going to invest in the lifestyle of an
MD somewhere because when you pay the
medical doctor your fee for going to see
him not one penny of that goes to study
how to diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease and a little child
like who was in here earlier or how to
prevent or diagnose or treat better
breast cancer or prostate cancer in
adults guess what that money goes for
pays the doctor's mortgage makes his
Mercedes payment pays a tuition for his
kids to go to medical school at havit
you know where havit is up in
Baston pays a tuition for his kids to go
to law school at Yale I believe because
we've made doctors wealthy between 1776
and the second world war the US
government spent $80 million on
Healthcare and Health Care research and
studies right now we're
1.2 trillion doll a year for healthc
care and it's free
we all know it's free
right I like that lady she says like
heck it's not free but we're supposed to
believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff I'll tell
you what if we used a human type medical
system for the agricultural industry and
the livestock your hamburger cost $275 a
pound on the other hand if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans your monthly
insurance premiums for a family of five
would be $10 a month
you take your choice well I believe
since we've made them wealthy through
Insurance programs and government
subsidies I believe they owe us
something I believe they owe us at least
as much as the uh Industries do
according to for instance recall notices
this was started of course I don't know
25 years ago when Ralph nater learned
that the Ford Motor Company had made a
pinto car with a rear-end gas tank that
would blow up when you got hit from
behind at 20 mph fry everybody in the
car and when people complain to Ford
Motor Company they said well you're just
dumb for getting in a car accident we're
not going to pay you for that Ralph
nater says no it's a faulty design so he
went to a federal court and the judge
agreed with him and through a court
order forced Ford Motor Company to send
everybody a recall notice with a
registered letter bring that car in and
they'll fix it for nothing but they kill
300,000 a year and nobody protests as
long as we get ours free and that scares
me that attitude at any rate I've got a
bunch of these recall notices you should
have gotten over the last couple years
we'll go through them quickly number one
is ulcers how many of you ever heard
that ulcers is caused by
stress okay everybody's heard that if
you don't raise your hand you got
Alzheimer's or your fibon
[Music]
right well we knew 50 years ago in in
the veterinary industry that uh ulcers
at least in pigs was caused by a
bacteria called helicobactor pylori and
of course we couldn't get one of these
high pric stomach surgeons from Mayo
Clinic in fact we always used to yell
hold the Mayo when they say stuff like
that and um otherwise your pork chops
would be $275 a pound to pay for that
kind of surgery and we learned that with
a trace mineral called bismuth and the
tetracycline antibiotic that we could
prevent and and cure those stomach
ulcers and pigs without surgery so
that's what we did cost five bucks to
cure a pig of stomach ulcers with the
Bismuth the trace mineral and
tetracycline well the National
Institutes of Health now not the
national Inquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February of this year February 1994 and
said ulcers are caused by a bacteria
called helic back or pylori not stress
and they can be cured they actually use
the Cure word in this news release
medical researchers never do that they
always say shows promising results or
may be beneficial they use the Cure word
National Institutes of Health and they
say can be cured with a combination of
the trace mineral bismuth and Tetra
cycling well for those of you who don't
know what bismo comes in you can get it
from any grocery store or drugstore it's
pink about 295 for an 8 O bottle and
it's called Pepto Bismol so a teaspoon a
day full of Pepto Bismol and some RM C
scour pellets you can take care of
ulcers now you have your choice where
you're going to treat your own for five
bucks or go get Whitted on that's your
choice then what's the number two cause
of death in Americans terrible disease
called cancer right now doctors get
information on cancer you'd think they'd
photocopy that and when they send you
that bill they should send you some
photocopies of this stuff well in
September of 1993 the um National Cancer
Institute not the national Inquirer but
the National Cancer Institute and the um
havid Medical School up in Baston did a
study on cancer patients and they came
out and they said an anti-cancer diet
was found well at any rate they picked
China to do this study because in one
Province henan Province in China they
have the highest rate of cancer in the
whole world it took 29,000 people for
five years in this study and what they
did was give them different vitamins and
minerals at Double the recommended daily
allowance for Americans now that's a
trivial amount for instance they use
vitamin C for one group and of course
the RDA a recommended daily allowance
for vitamin C is 60 milligrams double
that's to be 120 milligrams you can't go
into a health food store and find a
vitamin C tablet or capsule for less
than 500 milligrams for an adult and of
course lonus Pauling the gentleman with
two Nobel prizes says if you want to
prevent and treat cancer with vitamin C
you got to use 10,000 milligrams a day
well all the doctors who used to argue
with him back 35 years ago are all dead
and today L Pauling still 94 and he
works 14 hours a day 7even days a week
on his Ranch in the Big Sur in
California and teaches at the University
of California San Francisco so you have
to make up your choice whether you're
going to listen to the Dead Doctors or
lonus
Pauling your
choice okay vitamin C dou the RDA
nothing happened vitamin A Double the
RDA nothing happened zinc riboflavin the
trace mineral malum n nothing happened
in one group they got a major benefit in
this group they got three nutrients at
one time they got vitamin E they got
beta car
and the trace mineral selenium that
those three were at Double the RDA and
if you get a half a percent benefit in
any nutritional or pharmaceutical
experiment you've made a major
Improvement in Humanity's life and so
these articles get published so I want
you to remember that statistic a half a
percent is major benefit well in this
group that received the vitamin E beta
katene and selenium for five years
deaths from all causes were reduced by
9% almost 10 out of every hundred or one
out of every 10 who were going to die in
at 5 Years From Any cause
survived then cancers all cancers 13%
survived who would have died without
those three
nutrients so 13 out of 100 lived who
would have died and then the type of
cancer that was most prevalent in henan
Province stomach and esophageal cancer
21% lived who would have died 21 out of
100 lived now to me those are
significant numbers and your physician
for the number two cause of death in
America I should have sent every one of
you a photocopy of that at least giving
you information even if he doesn't want
to give you the advice give you the
information let you make up your own
mind well here's one I think is funny on
one hand and on the other side it tells
you the attitude of Physicians this has
to do with arthritis it was in um
September 24th 1993 that it was released
again it was from the havit medical
school in the Baston VA Hospital how
many of you in here have ever been to a
VA Hospital anybody in this room okay
good well you know the people who've
been to a VA Hospital you have two
opportunities to give your life for your
country country once on the field of
battle and the others in the VA Hospital
right well at any rate the title of the
release was chicken protein hals to
swelling and pain of arthritis in a
patient trial and what they did they
took people who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
these people got gold shots mesot
trexate they got aspirin prazone
cortisone everything else you can think
of physical therapy and the only thing
left for them was joint replacement
surgery okay now before Medical School
the VA hospital was going to give it to
him they said look we're looking for
some people who are willing to suffer
for 90 more days just three months
because want to try something a
short-term experiment and they got 29
volunteers and what they did for those
29 volunteers who failed to respond in
any way to medical treatment for
arthritis was they gave them a heaping
teaspoon full of groundup dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning just a heaping teaspoon of
ground up chicken carage and in 10 days
according to Harvard Medical School all
the pain and inflammation was gone these
are people who didn't respond in any way
to medical
treatment in 30 days they could open up
a new pickle jar that never been opened
and 90 days three months they had
maximum return of
function now here's the funny part the
funny part comes by a statement of the
guy who was the director of that study
from Harvard Medical School and here's
what he said quote listen to the words
are very important quote after 3 months
it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote because it worked
chicken cartilage had become
drug you can see he's thinking about
patent numbers and his eyes are rolling
around with 300 bucks a capsule 20
patients and you can just see him
calculating
right that means if you go to Kentucky
Fried Chicken and you buy a bucket of
chicken throw away the skin and the meat
and eat the ends off the bones you're
practicing medicine without a
license and if you go to a Kentucky
Fried Chicken in the middle of the night
in the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in the microwave
you know you're manufacturing a um
pharmaceutical and the FDA is going to
put you in
jail well if that's a little messy for
you you don't want to pay those launder
fees you can go into any grocery store
and get some nox gelatin women know
about noox jelatin because it's good for
your fingernails and your hair and your
skin it has the raw materials for
chicken cartilage has the raw material
for your cartilage
CU made out of beef cartilage and beef
tendon and if you take two of those
little half oun envelopes a day in your
orange juice and you take it with an
ounce per 100 pounds of body weight of
colloidal
minerals next time I come by here in
three months you're going to run up on
this stage and hug me and kiss me if you
got
arthritis how many you ever heard of
Alzheimer's disease everybody's heard
about it today 50 years ago when I was a
little kid there's no such thing as
Alzheimer's disease it's a new disease
one of those things just sort of
happened now it's a major disease one
out of every two people who reach age 70
get Alzheimer's disease pretty scary
well we learned 50 years ago in the
animal industry how to prevent and cure
in the early stages Alzheimer's disease
and livestock you imagine how much a
farmer would lose if the pigs were all
laying there scratching their head
saying why am I
here where is the feed box because if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day you're losing money right so we
learned in the agricultural industry how
to prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you say wall like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about a sophisticated
research medical school here University
of California San Diego came out and
said vitamin E eases memory loss in
Alzheimer's victims now they're only 50
years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so it might be safer going to a
veterinarian
then how many of you in this room ever
had a kidney stone anybody in here ever
get that kidney stone okay I see a few
in here what's the first thing a doctor
told you to give up nutritionally when
you got your kidney stone give up
calcium no Dairy no Dairy none of those
vitamin mineral things with calcium in
them because they have the stupid naive
ignorant belief that's pretty intense
they have the stupid ignorant naive
belief that the calcium in your kidney
stone comes from the calcium you eat
when in fact it comes from your own
bones when you have a raging Calcium
deficiency a raging osteoporosis then
you get kidney stones we learned a
thousand years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones and livestock you
better give them more calcium you better
give them more magnesium and more
Boron the reason is of course bulls and
rams male cattle and sheep have special
Anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they called water belly they
die when you and I get a kidney stone we
just wish we were dead but no farmer is
dumb enough to pay for the feed for an
animal and have it die before you can
either eat it or send it to Market so we
learned how to prevent those things well
you should have got a recall notice from
your doctor especially you people who've
had kidney stones your urologist should
have sent a notice to you this was about
15 months ago March of 1993 it says uh
calcium limits kidney stone risk and
this is from the havit medical school up
in Baston by the way in a study that
turns conventional medical wisdom on its
head researchers have found that people
whose diets are rich in calcium run to
reduce risk of developing kidney stones
in a study of more than 45,000 people
that who were ranked into five
categories the group that had the most
calcium had no kidney stones so it took
him a thousand years to catch
up now about five years ago when I
started out on this Crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one time zone and the next
and all over I knew I was going to get
crazy out there uh doing this last year
I was on the road 300 days out of the
Year 300 out 365 days and so I decided I
needed to have a that I could take with
me every time I get a little wacko I
could go in my room and do this Hobby
and I'd be okay you know be kind of like
having a little piece of home with me
wherever I went I wanted to have a hobby
that would uh uh help other people I
didn't want to collect baseball cards
because I like football and I didn't
want to do just cross word puzzles
because a good mental exercise but
wouldn't help anybody else and um I
couldn't take my compost pile I like the
garden and the hotels don't like that
you know so I decided I was going to
collect obituaries of doctors and
lawyers
[Music]
now as crazy as that sounds remember I
told you the doctors live to an average
age of 58 we Liv to 75.5 and here's a
group of people professionals who
pontificate you and tell you well this
is what you need to do you need to give
up salt and uh no caffeine and you need
to not eat butter and eat margarine and
do all these crazy things and they die
at age 58 on the average and of course
all those people who live to be 120 to
140 they put a chunk of rock salt in
their tea every day and they drink 40
Cups of Tea a day 40 chunks of rock salt
and they cook with butter instead of
olive oil and they live to be 120 so who
are you going to believe the people who
Liv to be 58 or the people who Liv to be
120 it's your choice anyway got a few of
them here some of my favorites this Dr
Stuart cartright aged 38 he dropped dead
in his home he was a family practitioner
of a ruptured aneurysm that's a
ballooning of an artery that's a
weakened artery because of the fragment
thing or the brittle condition of the
elastic fibers and arteries just like
when you hit a Chuck hole with your car
tire and you break the cords in there
and you get a
balloon he dropped dead like he was pull
axed okay right in his home from a
ruptured a Arctic aneurysm now we
learned in 19 oh I think it was uh
57 aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
250,000 turkeys we made complete food
pellets where you put all the 90
nutrients in there and in the first 13
weeks fully half of those turkeys died
125,000 of them farmers were out there
every morning picking them up by the
bushel basket they took them to the
state diagnostic labs and they autopsy
and they found out that they all had
died from a ruptured a Arctic aneurysm
so they doubled the amount of copper in
there and the next year they tried to
raise 500,000 turkeys and they didn't
lose a single turkey from a ruptured
Artic aneurysm and they ran that
experiment in mice and rats and rabbits
and dogs and cats and uh Cals and sheep
and pigs and whatnot and guess what they
found out that there's a whole series of
diseases that are caused by a copper
deficiency gray hair is the first sign
when you start getting gray hair
regardless of your age you got a copper
deficiency you get skin wrinkles because
the elastic fibers in your skin are
going those little crows feet around
your eyes and facial and body skin
wrinkles you look like you're a little
prune drying up okay then of course
there's the um uh varicose veins
varicose veins that's caused by an
elastic fiber breakdown then of course
parts of your body begin to Sag under
your arms your breast your belly your
legs all this stuff starts sagging and
you can go to a cosmetic surgeon or
plastic surgeon if you want but it's a
lot cheaper and a lot more effective and
a lot safer if you just take some copper
okay well Dr cartrite may have had a
medical degree but he didn't have
expensive urine so he died of something
that even a turkey Wouldn't Die from and
here's one this fellow he was a doctor's
doctor Dr Martin Carter he almost made
it he died at age
57 um he got his medical degree from
havit medical school and his PhD in
medicine from Yale of course um he was
autopsied by the best cuz he was a
doctor's doctor he said quote the cause
of death was a ruptured AR Artic
aneurism said Dr Jules HS the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
what did he die from copper deficiency
see he didn't have expensive urine
either and here's an attorney she was so
famous she was from Detroit age 44 Ellen
Joyce alter uh she was in the New York
Times obituary she made the big time and
uh of course she probably had steel buns
because she belonged to one of those
private health clubs all these gals want
steel buns you know doing their little
exercises but she didn't have expensive
urine because she died of a ruptured
cerebral
aneurysm when they don't do an autopsy
the symptoms could be called a stroke or
subdural Hemorrhage but very frequently
they're caused by a ruptured aneurysm
which is a copper deficiency she didn't
have expensive urine how many of you
here have ever heard of a guy by the
name of steuart burger Stuart Burger he
he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition uh he got
his medical degree from tough's medical
school which is a very fine medical
school in Boston not too far away from
uh Harvard Medical School and the books
he wrote included the Southampton diet
for weight loss he wrote Forever Young
20 years younger and 20 weeks and how to
be your own nutritionist and he died at
age
40 how' you like to follow his dietary
practices he died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy which is a selenium
deficiency the same causes white muscle
disease or or stiff lamb disease and any
farmer can go to a feed store and get
selenium pellets or selenium injections
things like celotto and boy and so forth
and Dr Stuart bur a guy who wrote five
bestselling books on nutrition died of a
nutritional
deficiency he didn't have expensive
urine now you can prevent totally
prevent cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a
day and if we don't do it we're
malignant dumb I like to call it you're
malignant dumb if you don't take in 10
cents a day worth of selenium it's a
waste of your life that's one of those
landmines you can avoid the medical
treatment of choice for cardiomyopathy
is a heart transplant CA
$750,000 I want you to think about that
they get the heart free from a
donor they get the blood free for the
surgery from the relatives they use
$2.50 worth of suture
material and they charge
$750,000 for that procedure now 6 months
ago in La when they had the earthquake
they were putting people in jail for 60
and 90 days for price gouging for
selling these terrified people a gallon
of water for
$4 they put them in jail for price
gouging for selling them a gallon of
water for four bucks now to me that's
entrepreneurialism you know that's being
in business for yourself if you had a a
way to distill water and make water and
you had a car and you could get in there
and sell those people a gallon of water
for four bucks hey more power to you
because if go to a 7-Eleven and buy a
quart of EV on water it's
$129 so four of those quarts is a five
bucks this is the end of side
one new heart they're terrified
$750,000 we should put those doctors in
jail but we bow to them because oh
that's high-tech medicine out of 270
million people in America you save about
50 a year is that cost effective I don't
think so I don't think so any rate Dr
Stuart burer didn't have expensive urine
and here's the last one and many of you
may know this woman her name was Dr Gail
Clark she was aged 47 she was the chief
cardiologist of the West St Louis County
group of hospitals uh she was a chief
cardiologist for the um St Mary's Health
Center in Richmond Heights in St Louis
County she was age 47 guess what she
died from heart attack a cardiopathy
heart attack you can just see her
walking down the hall she got the
stethoscope around her neck you know
this is their little status symbol got
my stethoscope around my neck back when
I was in school they folded it up very
bravely and put it in their
pocket boom she falls down she has a
heart attack right in the hall and of
course the nurse is scoop her up and put
her on a gurnie and they call the
technicians and another Docker code
three code three code blue whatever it
is and they whip her into the room and
you can hear them let's say you're a
cardiac patient you're laying there
you're all hooked up to the monitors and
the IVs and and you hear them say Okay
tear close off okay stand back didn't
work turn it up stand back and then you
hear that terrible sound when you know
that the didn't
work the Flatline when you know the
heart is gone and everybody walks out of
the room dejected and you say nurse
nurse what happened next door and she
says well your cardiologist you know the
chief cardiologist of this Hospital age
47 Dr Gail Clark just died of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack you can see
all the patients they're holding their
gowns and they're running out of that
hospital leaving their watches and their
shoes and their checkbooks and
everything and their plastic credit
cards because they don't want to get
what Dr Gail Clark got
got to me the reader digest is a
magazine that never says anything
negative or bad about anybody or any
group it's the sweetest little magazine
that ever was the September 1993 issue
features an article it says can you
trust your doctor it lists 12 ways the
doctors scam your money and I'll let you
read 11 of them yourself I'll give you
the worst
one in addition to their income from
Office fees and surgical fees and lab
fees and hospitalization in addition to
all those fees doctor get a kickback
from the labs and the the X-ray labs and
Clinics and hospitals they get a
kickback of
$421 every time they send you in for a
CAT scan or an
MRI and doctors tell you oh we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine because if I miss something one
in 10 billion you're going to sue me so
I do this just to protect myself well if
it was just to protect themselves and
you knew them and they knew you 90% of
the people say I'll just skip it dock if
you don't really think it's necessary
let's save the
money but they got something more than
the expensive medicine to worry about
they get 421 bucks in a kickback for
every time they send you in for an MRI
or a CAT scan well when I practiced for
12 years up in Portland somebody come to
me with a terrible headache never had
one I just walk up to them and tap them
on the sinuses and if they collapsed to
their knees I know they had a sinus
headache oh doc why'd you do that well I
just wanted that's a cheap lab test you
know then if they had thank
you if they had blood dripping out out
of their
nose if they had blood dripping out of
their nose I'd take a $35 x-ray to see
if they had a cancer in
there 35 bucks in a free lab test as
opposed to 421 bucks if I wanted to make
that 421 bucks I'd have been a good
Thief what I'd have done I'd have build
a shoot right into that cat scan machine
because I knew how to build shoots
living on a farm and I'd have gone out
in the street and I'd have got every
homeless person I'd line them up in them
shoots I'd put soup in a MIG Mac at the
end of that tube you know and i' say I'm
going to give buy you a 50 dinner I'm a
good guy I'm going to buy you a $150
dinner you just got to go through this
shoot go through that tube and you get
your sandwich and your soup man they'd
be flowing through there maybe a 100 a
day and I could start adding some things
up it'd be a lot of fun any rate the
average Docker gets
22,6 a year in cat scan Kickbacks a
quarter of a million dollars a year in
any other industry if you do that
politicians
lawyers businessmen stock brok ERS they
get put in jail but doctors it's
okay because insurance pays for it
Hillary will pay for it we don't mind if
they steal it's blind it's free well I
remember I told you I was going to tell
you about Pica Pica is a funny disease
Pica I'm not talking about the type
style that you see in typew Riders and
computers but p is a disease that
farmers know about in horses it's called
cribbing when they chew on the feed bunk
the wooden feed bunk you know you better
give them some minerals otherwise
they're going to eat that feed bum also
uh in cattle dairy cattle especially
they're losing lots of minerals through
their milk all the time intensive
milking you'll see them picking up big
rocks in the creek and chewing on them
or they'll chew on Bob wire or maybe
you'll see them walking down through a
path with a deer bone in their mouth or
something or a shingle that's called
Pica and a good farmer a husband
dreamman knows you better give them some
minerals otherwise they're going to eat
the barn or something in human beings we
see this at funny times pregnant women
are notorious for Pica uh in the middle
of the night they'll elbow their husband
and say Hey you better get up I want
some uh pickles and ice cream they're
craving minerals because that fetus is
pulling minerals out of their body they
need some more minerals and so it's it's
recognized as a craving for things like
sweets and salt and so forth we see this
in pregnant women I used to have people
come to my practice and they say do do I
need to go see a shrink I said why is
that well I wake up in the middle of the
night and I go outside with a spoon and
I eat dirt and no that's okay just make
sure it's clean
dirt then they say my my kid sits there
with a kitty litter box between his legs
and has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box and
then in housing projects little kids eat
lead paint off the walls and they get
lead poison get learning disabilities
and Bone problems and anemia and we're
good so we spend $5 million to scrape
the lead paint off of there and repaint
it with latex paint and all you have to
do is give those kids 10 cents a day
worth of minerals be better for them and
save us five million bucks it's your tax
money and if we allow him to throw them
away those dollars is kind of
interesting
any rate if you have a selenium
deficiency and you don't want to wait
until you get cardiopathy and drop dead
from a heart attack to recognize it if
you look on your hands and look in the
mirror in your face if you have liver
spots or age spots and I see quite a few
from
here you have an early selenium
deficiency that's called free radical
damage and fortunately for you if you
recognize that and you start taking in
some colloidal selenium in four to 6
months those will all go away you'll
reverse that in four to 6 months and
when they go away on the outside they're
going away on the inside your brain and
your heart and your liver and your
kidneys and if you have low blood sugar
how many in this room have low blood
sugar anybody in here have low blood
sugar okay about 10% how many you ever
seen a hyperactive kid who gets on
sugar okay about everybody in the room
people who have sugar problems are like
alcoholics there's good ones and bad
ones you know the good alcoholics are
one when they get two drinks they just
go off in a corner and go to sleep right
same way with somebody with low blood
sugar they eat a big meal or they eat a
piece of pie 3 hours later they clunk
out and go to sleep
then there's bad alcoholics they're the
one that gets two drinks in them and
they get violent and raged and they want
to fight everybody they punch holes in
the wall and you know big Brave fellows
and they kick their wife and kick the
dog and take the chainsaw and cut their
neighbor tree down and all these wild
things and drive Reckless down the roads
and kill people those are the bad drunks
well people who have blood sugar
problems are bad blood sugar people too
they a little crazy okay I don't know
how many of you remember the twinkie
defense right remember somebody murdered
two people and he claimed he ate a
Twinkie 3 hours before he murdered him
so they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar now don't any of you try
that well chromium and vadium deficiency
will result in the sugar problems low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vadium then a tin
deficiency the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency are male pattern baldness I
see a lot of tin deficiency in this room
yes and if you let it go on for any
length that time you get
deafness then there's a boron deficiency
and you gal should know about boron
because it helps you keep the calcium
you take in in your bones so you don't
get osteoporosis
Boron also it helps you make estrogen it
helps you fellas make testosterone if
you don't take in enough Boron you
ladies are going to suffer miserably
going through menopause okay you're
going to have all those terrible
symptoms you fellas don't get enough
Boron can't make testosterone you won't
know whether to lead or on the Dance
[Music]
Floor you're going to be
confused she's saying he's got a boron
deficiency then in laboratory oh I
should tell you too we said this on the
show today those of you may not have
heard it some of you didn't hear the
whole show the first symptoms of a zinc
deficiency is you lose your sense of
smell and your taste say oh you know
food just doesn't taste good anymore and
you don't have a cold or anything like
that you say your wife says well AR
aren't you excited about dinner I spent
the whole day in the kitchen cooking
dinner he said well I didn't smell
anything when I walked in you know he's
got a zinc deficiency well in laboratory
animals there's some seven rare Earths
these rare Earths are trace minerals you
need in lesser amounts than you need
trace minerals and they actually double
the lifespan of laboratory animals
they've not been proven in humans yet
but I'm not going to wait 500 years for
doctors to approve it they're still
arguing over vitamin C and calcium right
so I'm just going to do it didn't kill
any laboratory animals just doubles her
life and it's not a drug these r Earths
are called lanthum pran oium neodium
samarium europium yium and thulium there
must be a reason why they're named after
Old Testament cities well remember I
told you we needed 90 nutrients we need
60 minerals we need 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and of course
we're lucky in that plants as a group
can make most vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids plants can do that because
they just take carbon out of the air and
make carbon chains to make vitamins
amino acids fatty acids but you have to
eat 15 to 25 different plants a day in
the right combinations to make this
happen theoretically it's possible that
most Americans don't do it the average
American thinks if they eat some potato
buds out of a Betty Crocker box or
eating a vegetable okay so you got to be
careful what you're considering a
vegetable then of course people want to
do right by their doctor and they eat
lowfat turkey breast and they put a half
a jar of mayonnaise on there and they
put it between two slices of wond
Styrofoam bread remember that stuff you
can insulate your house with and put in
your shoes when you get a hole in shoe I
remember when I was a kid 50 years ago
it was a lot of fun because we have
Wonderbread we didn't have TVs back then
on the farm we didn't even have dryers
that went round and round so the only
thing you could do in the winter time
was sit in the kitchen and wonder at a
loaf of Wonderbread and had the blue and
red and green yellow balloons on there
and if you read the label as many times
as I do you know it said things like
helps build bodies at 12 ways and about
15 years later the FDA made him change
it to help build your body eight ways
now if you go to the store and look at
Wonder rappers it just says Wonderbread
so it kind of gives you a
clue so even though this is
theoretically possible it's not likely
to happen that you're going to get your
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids in
proper proportions from your diet and so
if your life is as valuable to you as
mine is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me I would make
sure that I take in all my vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids because I
guarantee you won't make it to 120 or
140 if you don't
you're just not going to do it now
minerals are another story we have a
tragic story when it comes to minerals
because plants cannot make minerals in
any way shape or form and if they're not
in the soil anymore they're not in our
plants we have for you when you leave a
free copy of a summary of US Senate
document 264 US Senate document 264 is
from a 74th Congress second session and
it says that our farm soils and our rain
soils are depleted of minerals and the
crops the grains the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that that are
grown on these depleted farm and Rain
soils are minerally deficient and the
people who eat them get mineral
deficiency diseases and the only way to
prevent and cure them is with mineral
supplements as US Senate document 264
74th Congress second session it was
written and printed by the US Congress
in
1936 58 years ago you think it's gotten
any better no it has not gotten any
better it's only gotten worse and the
reason is if you guys do what we did and
people continue to do is we put NPK on
our land nitrogen phosphorus potassium
and you see it as these three numbers
and many combinations of of ratios and
these represent percentages of these
three nutrients nitrogen phosphorus
potassium and those of you who don't
have any experience on farms the reason
why we do this is farmers get paid for
tons and bushels there's no subsidy that
encourages people to put 60 minerals
back in the soil you get paid for tons
and bushels and for 40 bucks an acre you
can get the maximum yield in tons and
bushels it only takes 5 to 10 years to
deplete the land of minerals because
every time you harvest a crop those
plants pull minerals out of the soil
many pounds per acre every time you haul
a crop out so as soon those minerals are
gone and if you only put back in three
and you take out 60 it's like a checking
account if you only put three bucks in
your checking account every month and
write checks for 60 what's going to
happen to your checks boing boing boing
they bounce exactly well I can tell you
that our health is bouncing right now to
the tune of $1.2 trillion a year year
because there's no more minerals left in
our soil it's our responsibility each
and every one of us to be responsible
for our health and consciously take in
these minerals I have a lot of people
ask me what did these people do
thousands of years ago they didn't even
have commercial fertilizers what did
they do these societies that had
longlived people and whatnot I want you
to think about the Egyptians the Chinese
people from India that lived around
these Great Rivers the Nile River the
Ganges River um the yo river in China
and what used to happen was every year
or so it would flood just like it did
here in Northern Missouri last year and
every time it flooded guess what would
happen it would bring silt or rock dust
from Mountains from 500 or thousand
miles away and those people would pray
to every God they had the water God the
sky God the wind God The Rock God to
flood we pray don't flood they used to
pray to flood because they had their
floods during the winter time and would
put silt and minerals back in the soil
and their drain was very valuable King
Philip who is the father of uh Alexander
the Great married the 12-year-old child
queen of Egypt Cleopatra she didn't look
like Elizabeth Taylor all made up in
beautiful costumes she was a little
flatchested teeny bopper not very sexy
but Philip married her because she
controlled the best wheat in the world
and if he wanted his Macedonian army to
conquer the world through his son
Alexander the Great he needed the best
wheat in the world so he could March 20
hours a day fight for 6 hours and win if
they used the wheat from the depleted
soils and grease they couldn't go 20
minutes without saying mommy pick me up
can you imagine these big Greek soldiers
Oh my legs hurt pick me up and so they
knew the best place to get wheat was
from
Egypt it was those floods that gave them
those minerals and all those cultures
that came up with all the great art and
all the great technology came from those
PE places because they had more
intelligence because they had more
nutrition more minerals I heard somebody
say very good we getting the picture
well what I'm going to do here is I'm
just going to pick out a couple of
minerals just a couple of them so get
the idea it applies to all of them let's
just pick out a common one like calcium
everybody knows about calcium Calcium
deficiency will result in something like
147 different diseases they're just
different names they're named after
people like Bell's py Bell's paly is you
know everybody knows about that one side
of your face sags it's not a true stroke
it just affects your facial muscles it's
caused by Calcium deficiency we'll talk
about in a little bit but everybody
knows about this one
osteoporosis the number 10 killer of
adults United States it's very expensive
it cost you $35,000 each for each hip to
replace it's okay it's free insurance or
Medicare or Hillary will pay for it cost
you $70,000 for both hips as expensive
as it is and number 10 killer remember
Mrs ski from Radford Virginia aged 115
years of age he died of complications of
a fall we don't have osteoporosis and
animals and it's because of farmers we
don't have osteoporosis and animals goes
like this you have have a a pasture with
100 cows in it and this year you didn't
have any calves you can't repay your
operating loan you're in trouble right
because you paid for the feed and the
vet bill and mow the pasture and
fertilize and maintain the fence and fed
the cows and all this that and the other
you don't have any cash you can't pay
back the oper operating load and make
any money so you call the vet out and
you say do I get rid of these cows what
happened here and he examines the cows
he says nothing wrong with them says let
me look at the bull he say aha here's
your problem that bull has osteoporosis
with both hips can't breed the cows
didn't have any Cales he says I'll tell
you what though he says you give me
$70,000 he says I'll put two new hips in
that bulll next year you'll have some
Cals well the first thing that farmer
says is stand back doc
boom he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle and while the kids are grinding
the kid the well the kids are grinding
the bull up with um a grinder and
cutting roast and steaks off that bull
the farmer is chewing on a straw saying
now Doc pushes stepson up a little bit
and he says you know he says uh you know
I wasn't going to pay you $70,000 for
that old bull he says I get a new bull
every year for 70 years for that he says
but every once in a while I get a bull
that throws good calvs I'd like to keep
them is there any way I can prevent that
osteoporosis thing for happen to a good
bull he says well yeah he says if you'll
give a bull CF 10 cents worth of calcium
every day after he's weaned he'll never
get osteoprosis for wait a minute doc
you mean if I give that bull 10 cents a
day worth of calcium from the time he's
wean I can prevent a
$70,000 disaster oh yeah it's that
simple he says you mean all I have to do
is give up a half a cup of coffee a day
to do that he says yeah that's it he
says I choose that one he say I'll give
up the half a cup of coffee and that's
what we have to think like okay then
there's receding
gums dentist and periodontist will tell
you that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums you better floss and brush
after every meal if you believe that
works I have some oceanfront property in
Montana to sell you if you all know your
geography you know that doesn't work now
as a veterinarian I've seen hundreds of
thousands of animals of all kinds mice
rats rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs horses
lions and tigers and bears and they
don't get receding gums and they don't
floss now they do get funky breath but
they don't get receding gums well if you
want to smell something you just let a
camel breathe on you
[Music]
boy well the reason we don't have
receding gums and livestock is because
we've dealt with the osteoporosis
problem receding gums is not a
deficiency of flossing it's in fact
osteoporosis of the jaw bones and the
facial bones so if you have gingivitis
or receding gums you have advanced
osteoporosis those bones around your
teeth are melting away little bit by
little bit every day and if you take
your teeth out at night and put them in
a glass next to your bed and that fizzy
stuff you have major advanced
osteoporosis because all your bone has
melted away okay then there's
arthritis we talked about that a little
bit earlier remember the chicken
cartilage or the noox gelatin 85% of all
arthritis is caused by osteoporosis of
the joint ends of the bones you're
talking about degenerative arthritis
osteoarthritis sciatica lumbago
rheumatism all those sorts of things um
they're caused by osteoporosis of the
joint ends of the bones I want you to
think about something for a minute if
you don't take a pain reliever or or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis
let's say you get arthritis of the hips
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit aren't you you're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches
you're going to favor it and so you
don't put any weight on it I want you to
think about that for just a second
because then I want you to think about
driving your tractor in a field or
you're driving a Mercedes down the
highway either one doesn't matter
whichever you love more and um let's say
you didn't put the nut on that oil pan
real tight and all the oil drained out
and that light on the dashboard comes on
says I'm getting hot you better give me
some oil and that light irritates you so
you stop you open up the hood you get
your clippers out you know your fence
Clippers and you clip the the wire to
that light and you close the hood and
you just keep driving would you do that
to your tractor or your Mercedes no you
wouldn't but we take those pain
relievers for arthritis and we go out
there and square dance and do the Texas
step and do our F mile walks and our
aerobics that pill Works real good doc
cuz it kill my pain and you're just
wearing that thing off faster and
faster then your doctor's really going
to get rich because you need joint
replacement
surgery then there's hypertension this
is one of my favorites so I'll put a
star over
here hypertension is high blood pressure
what's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritionally when you get high blood
pressure give up up salt everybody knows
that one that's been ingrained in our
head well they must think we're dumber
than cows because what's the first thing
you put out for your livestock and about
that big ass salt block no farmer is
going to be economically viable if you
don't put a salt block out for your
livestock they're going to die kind your
Veterinary bills are going to go crazy
but we're supposed to believe that we
don't need salt you can get everything
you need out of your lettuce and your
whole wheat bread and stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that I got some more ocean
front property in Montana for you
remember those long people put a big
chunk of rock salt the size of a big
black concord grape in every cup of tea
and they drink about 40 Cups of Tea a
day because they live at high altitudes
it's very dry they have to keep hydrated
and they put butter in their tea they
put two Pats of butter and a chunk of
rock salt they don't put the pink stuff
or the blue stuff or skin milk or what
do they call it uh creora or whatever it
is okay guess guess what the doctors who
live to be 58 tell you no salt no butter
the people who live to be 120 they put
in butter and salt so you got to make
some choices well they took $30 million
of your tax money and two years ago
after a 20-year study they came out and
said that they took 5,000 people with
high blood pressure they took them off
their medication and put them on a
reduced salt diet a restricted salt diet
and they all died no big surprise but
somebody got a PhD degree and everybody
was happy right but when they looked at
this results they said that oh only
99.7% of the people didn't get any
results from that before before they
died 0.3% did get some result dropped
their blood pressure one point before
they died by restricting their salt so
the referees who judged that article
said oh doesn't matter you might as well
let high blood pressure patients eat
salted peanuts and deal pickles and salt
their food to taste because it doesn't
matter in fact worrying about the salt
is more stress than taking the salt then
they had a control group with 5,000
people with high blood pressure and they
doubled their RDA of calcium and they
stopped the experiment in 6 weeks
because 85% of them were cured of their
high blood pressure just by doubling
their calcium intake now they didn't
cold turkey stop their high blood
pressure medication but what they did
was they went to the doctor and says you
don't need this medication anymore what
are you doing well I'm on this
experiment where I double my calcium
intake anybody get a recall notice from
your doctor saying it's okay to Salt
your food to taste and please do double
your calcium intake anybody get that not
a single one that's very interesting
then of course there's insomnia that's
where you roll around all night and you
get your you wake up in the morning
you're more tired when you went to bed
that's insomnia of course doctors have
two treatments for that they have hion
which is a sleeping pill and they have
barbituates they kill about 10,000
people a year with overdoses of those
things but that's okay it's in
prescription and they're watching out
for us and remember remember uh George
Bush when he went to Japan they gave him
some helon so he could sleep on the way
to Japan because of the time difference
and when he woke up one of the the side
effects of helon is nausey and
vomiting I don't know how you say it in
Japanese but it was very dramatic on
world TV right not very
presidential and so I'm sure that's why
he lost the election because he puked
over that Japanese
[Music]
Ambassador and then of course there's
kidney
stones and then there's bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits again
Physicians will tell you the first thing
to give up nutritionally is calcium and
dairy because they have this foolish
belief the stupid belief the ignorant
belief that the calcium in kidney stones
bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits come from uh your diet when
instead it only comes from your bones
when you have a raging osteoporosis and
when you get these things you need more
calcium not less then there's cramps and
Twitches you wake up in the middle of
the night and your foot is all cramped
up around your neck and you say Lord
take me from the knee down I'm not going
to make it till morning we've all
experienced that that's very
common then PMS premenstrual syndrome
you know the emotional and physical
stuff the medical treatment of choice
for PMS is what we call a hysterical
ectomy it's been shortened to
hysterctomy that's a 100- year old
treatment the doctors do about 285,000
unnecessary hysterical ectomies a year
but it makes Mercedes payments so they
do them even the AMA said they're
unnecessary but they don't take their
licenses away and people keep going to
them you imagine a poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time I go out to hang out the
clothes my neighbor kids run down the
basement screaming which my own kids
think I'm crazy my husband's leaving me
I'm going to lose my job you got to do
something well the University of
California San Diego came out three
years ago now and said if you just
double the RDA of calcium intake you get
rid of 85% of the emotional and physical
symptoms of PMs and when that came out
there were huge lines around the health
food stores around the blocks and people
had sleeping bags CU they closed before
they all got their calcium and every
person in line was a
man they were there for their daughters
and their girls friends and their wives
and things like that okay and lastly is
low back pain 85% of Americans get low
back pain whether you work on a computer
or you unload hay or you drive big
trucks doesn't matter low back is a big
problem low back is just osteoporosis of
the vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or whatnot because if your disc
doesn't have anything to hold on to your
vertebrae melted away what's going to
happen to the disc especially if you
have a copper deficiency because they're
made out of elastic fibers they go like
a water balloon with a lot of pressure
on them well I just want you to look at
this quickly before we do the last
mineral low back you go to an orthopedic
surgeon or rheumatologist you might get
a muscle relaxant you might get valium
and a muscle relaxant you get a
laminectomy you get your vertebrae fuse
you might get a disc operation they
don't tell you 75% of the time you'll
never be the same again right PMS you go
to your
OBGYN you can um go to an internist you
can go to a family counselor a shrink or
divorce attorney CR and Twitches you go
to a neurologist you go to a sports
medicine doctor an internist bone spurs
heel spurs calcium deposits you go to a
rheumatologist an orthopedic surgeon or
a podiatrist kidney stones you go to a
urologist or an internist or a surgeon
insomnia you go to a shrink or a um
Sleep Clinic or an internist
hypertension you go to a Cardiologist an
internist or a surgeon arthritis a
rheumatologist a orthopedic surgeon or
an internist receding gums you go to a
dentist or periodontist osteoporosis you
go to all those health specialist
including a tum salesman for nothing
more than a Calcium deficiency it cost
you 10 cents a day to deal with now on
the average because Americans have
insurance and we have Medicare and
Medicaid we spend on the average $25,000
to
$250,000 and we undergo 5 to 10 surgical
procedures a year for a Calcium
deficiency we beg the doctors to do it
we beg the doctors to do it well it's
our choice the last one I'll share with
you is diabetes everybody's touched by
diabetes it's the number three cause of
death in adults in the United States
number three cause of death and it has
terrible complications and side effects
diabetes the side effects include
blindness of many
kinds then there's a kidney failure with
dialysis and kidney transplant there's
cardiovascular disease of all kinds and
of course that contributes the number
one cause of death which is the number
one cause of death uh then there is
amputations everybody ought to have one
of those cuz they're totally paid for in
your health thing because they assume
that you're not just going to get one
because you want to get everything on
your health benefits and then you
shorten your life because if you have
diabetes on the average you have a
shorter lifespan than someone who
doesn't have diabetes now we learned in
1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals that's a pretty profound
statement that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals in 1957
and animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
official Journal of the American Science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly Journal was August
1957 well the two trace minerals that
you can get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and vadium vadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School vadium
alone will replace
insulin in addal onset diabetics which
represent 85% of all diabetics of course
they can't quit their insulin cold
turkey they got to gradually wean off of
it takes four to six months for most
people to slowly wean off of insulin if
they're taking in adequate amounts of
chromium and vadium I've seen it work on
hundreds and hundreds of people now to
me this is Criminal because if you write
to a Hills packing company that makes
signs. dog food right over here in topa
Kansas I don't know if I'm pointing West
but that way okay they're all saying
that
way topa Kansas they manufacture Science
Diet dog food and other Science Diet
product high-tech foods for Animals if
you write them and say how many minerals
exactly as in Science Diet for dog food
they'll write you back and say there's
40 minerals you write checkerboard
Square in St Louis R and pan say just
how many minerals are in your rat
pellets for laboratory rats and they'll
say there's 28
minerals I'll give anybody in this room
a crisp new $100 bill if you can find me
a human infant formula in a grocery
store that has more than 11 so our dogs
get farty minerals remember that's what
Mike Murphy was saying his dog never
seems to get sick cuz he's getting this
canned dog food with all these vitamins
and minerals in there so our dogs get 40
minerals our rats get 28 minerals and
our human infants get 11 is that fair no
that's called
thr doesn't matter if you're talking
about SMA Similac Isomil Pro soy B fact
that's why they call Similac Similac
because it lacks
[Music]
everything okay if I've convinced you
that you have to consciously take in all
the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food and certainly you
can't depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled there's three types
of minerals that you have to be
concerned about one is metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
ground up rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell eggshell
Dolomite Limestone uh calcium carbonate
Clays of various kinds Mount marinite
clay seabed minerals there
TS they're only 8 to 12% absorbable When
You Reach age 35 to 40 it drops down to
3 to 5% and I have to tell you a story
here some of you heard this on the show
today I ran into a guy at a meeting like
this up at Grand Rapids Michigan and
this fell owns a porta potty business
you know that's that green or blue
colored ouse man if we' only had one of
those back when I was a kid we had these
ones with splinters you know in the in
the wood any rate um he said I see some
something that that describes that in my
Porta poot business I said what's that
he says well we take those things back
to the shop to clean them out with a
pressure hose he says we put a quarter
inch grid underneath them because kids
throw rocks and sticks and toys in there
and if we don't put a grid there it
blocks up the sewer system it cost us
thousands of dollars to fix it he says
every time we clean one of those out we
find hundreds of vitamin tablets I said
well how do you know they're vitamin
tablets he says well that's really easy
he says right on the coating it says
terram M One A Day
Centrum he says come here he takes me
out in the back of his shot and there's
this literal mountain of all these
vitamin pills he got out of his porta
potties that's because you can't absorb
metallic minerals if you read the labels
on those multiples they say your iron
comes in the form of iron oxide what is
iron oxide
rust you might as well just go out to an
old railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it and you're going to get your
iron supplement that's what they're
giving you well I'll show you how bad it
is if you take something like calcium
lactate was which is a common metallic
mineral let's say it's a calcium tab
calcium lactate 1,000 Mill
if you take two of those you're not
getting 2,000 milligrams of calcium in
fact I have people all the time say well
I took lots of calcium doc I hear you on
the radio talking about calcium and
arthritis and I took 2,000 milligrams of
calcium a day didn't help my arthritis
in fact it got worse and said what kind
of calcium you taken they said calcium
lactate well there's your problem
because only 250 milligrams of that is
metallic calcium so let's say you absorb
10% of that then the other 750
milligrams is lactose or milk
sugar so 10% of 250 is 25 so if you take
two of those tablets you're not getting
2,000 you're getting 50
milligram so to get what you need you
need to take 90 of those tablets a day
you need to take 30 with each meal and
you got 59 more minerals to
go and there's those people who want to
do things naturally let's see if you can
do anything good with 10 pounds of
spinach and let's be fair let's see if
you get 1,000 milligrams of magnesium
and pick magnesium because in green
leafy vegetables you have a lot of
magnesium because of the chlorophyll
right part of the chlorophyll molecule
and any pound of anything you got 454 G
and 10 L pound of spinach you got 4540 G
of which most of that 97% is water let's
say you have one gram of chlorophyll and
that 10 pounds of spinach there's 50
milligrams of magnesium you got to
divide that into the Thousand you want
you get a factor of 20 which you
multiply times the 10 you have to eat
200 lbs of spinach you got 58 more
minerals to go okay so you got to be a
pretty big person to accomplish all this
even as big as I am you can't get it
done so I prefer to supplement rather
than do those things then of course
during the 60s the agricultural industry
came up with Keel minerals chelated
minerals because Farmers aren't dumb
enough to pay for a dollar of something
that goes into an animal's mouth and
have 99 Cents come out in the manure so
I have to really thank Farmers for being
that clever and chelated minerals are
just metallic minerals with an amino
acid or protein or enzyme wrapped around
the metal atom and increase the
absorbability to 40% then the hell food
industry jumped on that right away
because it was a major Improvement in
absorbability of minerals the most
efficient way to absorb minerals is the
colloidal Farm colloidal minerals are
98% absorbable 2 and a half times more
available than chelated minerals and 10
times more available than metallic
minerals and they're very interesting
they're liquid they can only be liquid
can't be pills powders or uh capsules
they're very small particle size are
seven ,000 times smaller than a red
blood cell and they're negatively
charged every particle is negatively
charged your intestinal lining is
positively charged so you actually have
an electrical or magnetic gradient that
concentrates these minerals around the
lining of your intestine these three
things together give you the 98%
absorbability now plants have a very
interesting part to play in colloidal
minerals remember we said that plants
cannot create minerals they're not in
the soil plants can't make them remember
the US Senate document to 64 says
they're not in the soil anymore at any
rate metallic minerals are taken up by
plants when they're in the soil plants
convert them in their tissues to
colloidal minerals and this is how we
store minerals in our body this is how
we use minerals in our body this is how
we transport minerals from their storage
place to their site of use in the
colloidal form well our plants our crops
don't have much in the way of colloidal
minerals in them because we don't have
any metallic minerals in our soil is
this important well yeah these long live
cultures who live to be 120 to 140 they
have certain common denominators they
all live in high mountain Villages that
are above 8,500 to 14,000 ft in
elevation they all have less than two
inches of precipitation a year they
don't have any rain they don't have any
snow they don't have any Dew okay very
very dry places and guess what they get
all their drinking water and all their
irrigation water for their crops from
what we call glacial milk glaciers in
every one of those communities grind up
the parent rock of those mountains about
4 in a year there's more than 60 to 72
minerals in each one of those places
the water that comes out from underneath
those glaciers is not clear like perer
or Evan water or Poland water or geyser
water you take a glassful of it up and
hold it up it looks like Jersey milk I
mean it is either yellow white or white
blue it looks like milk and it's called
in titty cocka I got to say it again in
titty Kaka or Tibet they all call it
glacial milk because it looks like milk
and not only have they consumed it drunk
it and got 8 to 12% until they were 35
to 40 then 3 to 5% absorption for 2500
to 5,000 years depending on the culture
more importantly they have irrigated
with it year after year crop after crop
generation after generation for 2 200 to
5,000 years they have no diabetes they
have no heart disease no high blood
pressure no arthritis no osteoporosis no
cancer no cataracts no glaucoma they
have no birth
defs they have no jails full of drug
addicts they have no taxes they have no
doctors
yet they live to be 120 to 140 without
disease are these collidal minerals
important You Bet Your Life they're
important and every time you don't take
them in every day you're chopping off a
few hours or a few days of your life
okay now most people are not going to go
to hanza or Tibet or titty
Kaka because we don't have kenm more
kitchens there or even Saturn cars or TV
Changers Channel Changers or electricity
they don't have insulated houses they
don't have
heating or air conditioning but what
they do have is colloidal
[Music]
minerals this is Dr wall with a final
message information gives you the
ability to make decisions with
confidence I hope you've enjoyed my
message by giving your body the proper
raw materials every day you'll be taking
the necessary steps in living healthier
and living longer make the decision to
take control of your personal Health and
Longevity program today Cal minerals are
not like antibiotics you don't get a
prescription which you use for 10 days
and then you're done your prescription
for colloidal minerals should only
expire when your need for oxygen expires
you need to supplement your diet with
the 90 essential nutrients each and
every day of your life millions of
people have heard my message all across
the world and have now decided to make
the consumption of colloidal minerals a
daily ritual just as there are many
manufacturers of aspirin there are now
many manufacturers of vitamins and
mineral supplements be sure to get your
liquid colloidal minerals derived only
from the very best organic plant Source
deposits colloidal minerals are the
mineral Source our bodies were designed
to use not ground up rocks since you
will most likely be supplementing your
diet each and every day don't get caught
paying retail prices my daddy always
said why pay retail when you can buy
wholesale one of my trusted colleagues
will show you how to purchase the
highest quality products wholesale so
you can save gob's money off the retail
price each year the distributor whose
name and phone number is on this Cass
will be happy to help you live long and
[Music]
[Applause]
prosper pretty amazing stuff isn't it so
the next thing you do is you go back to
the person who sent you the link to this
video and you order any product that
addresses your afflictions from them and
that's how you go about doing it if you
did not get that from a current
youngevity associate then find somebody
who is and give them the credit for it
because there is a commission that's
paid on whatever you order it's only
fair to give them that credit if you do
not have anyone that you've used before
then and only then do you go to my
website and there's a link to it also
below and that's when you can take care
of the ordering and you've seen
throughout this video as I've as I've
gone through different things how um how
you go about ordering from the website
I've just been scanning this as you've
been going through the website you go
through I want to join and select your
country and take care of all the
enrollment from there uh one thing I'll
explain for you though is that when you
go to the enrollment page first you're
probably going to want to be a a
preferred customer because you want to
try stuff out first before you decide
whether you want to make this a business
and so you'd select this one fill in
your
registration once you've done that you
can go back and order products and get
30% off the purchase price it's a pretty
decent deal now if you want to turn this
into a business different deal then you
go over to the left side you f that out
and then you select one of the four CEO
packs that's listed right here and it'll
cost you
$399.99 plus uh taxes in shipping and if
you're in the United States it'll come
out to about 435 bucks it's well worth
it though because you'll want to do this
if you want to build a tree and that's
and that tree is one thing I've shown
you right here in this form right here
it's it shows you as a CEO versus
somebody who wants to sign up just as a
distributor and so that chart's
available for you to take a look at as
well along with my phone number and
website number of other things I showed
you a list of ailments as well as uh
cures that people have listed over time
and I've gone through several of these
um as I've come through them over the
years it's probably been like 5 10 years
I've been assimilating these things and
just looking at the testimonials both on
youngevity as well as elsewhere what
people can do for all these different
ailments I mean you've got things all
the ma major stuff the biggest thing
that we see stuff on all the time is
weight loss
every single day literally when I go on
the longevity website I see somebody
posting a good positive comments on
youngevity's products for losing weight
um that ASAP product the little drop
things they're always commenting how
good that is but there's other stuff
that's good for it too and we're talking
major stuff look at that cancer
arthritis Alzheimer's kidney stones male
baldness
menopause uh sexual dysfunction
overweight
antioxidants um eczema autism
Parkinson's that's a big thing I I know
a lot of people with Parkinson's now too
osteoporosis wrinkles name it it's
probably on this list and if you don't
find it on this list you can always
email me John finger my9 forlife.com and
I'll be happy to look into it for you
what else did we want to cover here
there's Dr Wall's picture as he looks
nowadays uh and that's pretty much it so
uh go back and take a look at all this
stuff get enrolled and get yourself
healthy again and also send this link to
your friends so they can go out and take
a look at this video as well and improve
their lives there's no reason for you to
benefit doctors all your life when you
now know you have all the weapons
necessary to take care of your own
health so as Dr Wallock says go forth
and prosper